[Music]
alright hey everybody a beautiful day
here in LA huh oh yeah I spent the whole
day today on Facebook let me ask you
guys this you guys ever Google something
you notice on your Facebook wall there's
an ad for the thing you googled well
what the hell is that I was on my
facebook wall day there was an ad for
sexy Cougars I was like hey Google that
was between us what the hell are you
doing buddy I thought I could tell you
anything you're blabbing the neighbors
take it easy now I'm all nervous around
Google now it's like that guy can't
trust anymore round now every time I
google something I'm very ambiguous now
I'm like spicy Latinas for a friend
yeah the Internet's a crazy thing I just
got an email from a hot gay guy this hot
gay guy email me gorgeous gay man
smoking hot what a bummer I'm not gay
this guy's a 10 yeah a hot gay guy
having a crush on you it's kind of like
finding a million pesos
you're like oh man I can't do much about
this now but once I crossed that line
I'll be set
[Applause]
I like the gays any gay guys here well
that is statistically impossible gay
guys are the best another but perks you
know they're nonviolent they fix up
neighborhoods and they're generally
smart people you never really meet an
ignorant gay guy never meet a gay guy
was like
I only love three things my truck my gun
and dick you never hear that you know
and I had a guy's say to me once hey
Mark you like gays so much but what if
you had a gay son I wouldn't mind having
a gay son having a gay sons like finding
a french fry and your onion rings you
know you're like well it's not what I
expected but I like these two I am not
gay do like the gals went on a date with
a girl once I went pretty well I'm back
to her place I take out a condom she
goes whoa whoa whoa where'd you get that
thing I was like well they were free at
the bar she was like oh that's gross I
was like well that's where I got you
and you know these are all just jokes I
don't mean to offend the gals I try to
be a good feminist I do which is tough
nowadays cuz some women are feminist and
some women aren't so as a guy how do I
know how to act like some girls open the
door for and they're like wow a
gentleman they're very much
other girls you open the door for them
they're like wait you think I can't on
my own door I'm like well hey I'm just
trying to sleep with you
I do feel sorry for women when it comes
to sex though I think you guys get
screwed over you know guys sex a lot of
girls is a cool guy girl has sex a lot
of guys everybody makes fun of her
that's not fair it's a double standard I
hate when guys pull this move they go
you know I had sex with that girl I'm
the man and go yell she had sex with him
too and they go what a [ __ ] well that's
not fair how come she's a [ __ ] now come
join us that when she had sex with you
you never hear guys say that whoo she
banged me what a [ __ ] wow you've got
some problems sister get your act
together this this is a wake-up call I
feel like we're so mean and promiscuous
girls in society aren't we [ __ ] [ __ ]
she's loose she's easy well what is that
don't we all like sex well get mad at
the one group giving it away yeah we all
like Banana Republic they have a sale
and nobody calls them a [ __ ] I don't
get it we got a black president now gay
marriage is legal here yet [ __ ] are
still oppressed that's the one group in
this country that still gets stepped on
I don't know why guys stick it up for
these women even women won't stick up
for them those [ __ ] are ruin it for
everybody
no you could put out - I genuinely don't
understand I feel like we're gonna make
fun of a group of girls let's make fun
of the prude girls right now the boring
annoying ones let's kick them off the
high horse they've had it too good for
too long yeah why do we reward these
women oh I don't put out till three
months in a relationship yeah you have
nothing else to offer get a personality
get that come on kick it up a notch
let's go
cuz that's be honest you know prude
girls they're like mom and pop shops we
all pretend to like them but they're
more expensive when they close early
for misc us girls are like Walmart
alright everybody makes fun of them
everybody talks down to them when you're
inside one at four in the morning you're
like man I'm glad these are around
[Applause]
you